Republican Florida Governor Ron DeSantis  says that if Apple removes Twitter from  the App Store it would Merit a response  from the U.S Congress Elon Musk is  actually opening it up for free speech  and is restoring a lot of accounts that  were unfairly and illegitimately  suspended for putting out accurate  information about covid and as you can  obviously tell Ron DeSantis is a small  government conservative he wants the  government involved in the smallest  number of things only when government  involvement is absolutely necessary for  the survival oh the app store right it's  another example of how their stated  principles are thrown in the toilet and  flush 10 to 15 times as soon as they're  no longer convenient